Welcome everyone to tilt that Google,
I'm doing it and you want to outsource.
And I'm the country manager
of was born in Nigeria.
We have a special guest today
and that is the big beautiful.
Uh, today is uh, a special
international women's Day as it shows.
The theme for this year is being both
the king you both with [inaudible],
we've taken inspiration from bath and
the theme of this is being bold in
entrepreneurship and I think we'll exam
his vice boldness in entrepreneurship.
So once again, thank you for being
here. Thank you for inviting me here.
This is good to be here. It's good to
be here. Thank you for the invitation.
Fantastic.
Yes.
So I'm going to start by reading her
profile and then we'll get into the
conversation.
So more of a do has that achieved success
in various fields plus as an executive
in Exxonmobil when nearly a decade as a
promoter behind the Hotel Hotel Oakwood
Park, as well as the founder
of big Lawrence and associates,
one of Nigeria's leading outsourcing.
Okay.
She ends up in the world of media as the
Creator and hostess of moments with Mo
earning the accolade of
Africa's first lady of chats.
The show was the first stuff.
It's time to be syndicated across
Africa with an impressive guests.
This that includes Hillary Rodham Clinton,
President Muhammadu Buhari and
Christine Lagarde amongst others.
Three years ago she
launched everybody light TV,
which is Africa's first
global entertainment and
lifestyle network or premium
homegrown entertainment.
And in 2014 she started ebony life films.
I Deb you film 50 I have second
film, the wedding party. Yay.
In partnership with the Elphick
film collective, both primary APP,
prestigious international film
festivals and broke box office records
nationwide.
I think that is
well,
it is highly sought after
in depth knowledge on the
African and global creative
industry.
She has spoken at the University
of Cambridge Judge Business School.
What is school of business?
How would university and
New York University Stern
School of business amongst
others wall has received international
recognition by Forbes as the first
African woman.
So lunch of [inaudible] TV as well
as Africa is most successful woman.
Hey,
yeah,
those have been recognized by CNN as
Africa is Queen of media who conquered the
continental. So once again,
welcome. Thank you for having me.
It's really great to have you
guess which is a whole team
switching roles. So, um, a
lot of people have journals,
right?
And a lot of people struggle to make the
jump required to achieve those dreams,
especially when it involves
going into a new space.
Now that's something you've done quite a
few times in your career from the early
days you left the security
of a upbeat employment.
So to set up an HR consultancy firm,
we glorious associates.
Subsequently you started
a talk show moments we mo,
which was new territory for you.
What inspired you and give you the
courage to take those initial steps?
When I decided to leave as a mobile,
it was a really big
jump for me because yes,
there's nothing like working in oil
and gas in Nigeria. I mean it's a,
it's a job for life so to speak,
unless you do and you to doable.
But if you just go to work
and do the normal things,
you know, you get paid well,
you know,
you've got a pension or build a nice house
and everything really if they need to
be just fine.
Um,
but I think that as an
entrepreneur or for me, you know,
there's this,
for me,
there was this unsettling feeling that
there was certain things that I felt that
I had to do.
And I think when that feeling comes,
it's,
it can be obsessive.
It can almost be as if it's an
addiction of some sorts. You know,
you just feel that you have
to do everything within
your power to achieve that
particular obsession.
So yes,
I had a great job and the other day it
was actually the birthday of the ta to
the old deal of Exxonmobil.
So she had invited me to come and it
was just last Friday and I went along to
enter and I saw all that.
They were colleagues there and
I was thinking to myself, wow,
it could have been a
really comfortable life.
But then I decided otherwise.
And the thing is that
when you decide otherwise,
there are no guarantees about
that decision that you have taken.
You don't know how it's gonna turn
out. So at times I'm like, my God,
what about if we had gone wrong?
You know.
But I think sometimes you need to take
those steps because what really happens
if it goes wrong? What is the what?
What is? So for me I'm always like,
what is the possible worst
thing that can happen?
The possible wasn't that can
happen is go to get another job.
So I think once you understand that
you are not afraid of what's the worst
outcome can be and you then look at the
positivity of what the upside can be and
then once you are prepared,
I think preparation is important.
You can't just go into wanting to leave
paid employment without having had a
secure plan about what you're going to
do once you have left paid employment.
So before I left,
I was kind of like walking on two sides
of the street at the same time. You know,
it had started that Rollins
already working with Exxon Mobil.
You have to declare absolutely everything.
So I declared that I did have an
interest in a consulting firm.
We were doing some business.
I did employee some stuff to
look after the business for me.
So when I could see that there was,
there were many more possibilities and
I can't achieve those possibilities by
staying in a nine to five job,
a then had to decide about resigning.
And I was warned about resigning.
I was told that Melissa,
you can go to his project and I've gone
to Houston on sort of three months,
you know, I'm sort of out of
station work opportunities, um,
some shorter. So I had all
this opportunities there. Um,
and also there's more you can grow
hair, why you'd buy my, he said, well,
don't leave. And I just said,
I have to leave, you know,
and I just have that
punch knowing that okay,
once I'm out of it as a mobile,
I have no alternative now than to do
absolutely everything within my power to
make that transition work.
So I did plenty of notice,
six months notice.
And whilst I was doing that,
it was sort of trying to
build up on the outside,
sort of find an office and find stuff
and you know that Vic Lawrence on the
right footing so it can be staring.
You can't just leave.
You do have to plan. There are no
guarantees and is going to work,
but I always believe that
you know with a great plan,
if you're ready to work hard
and if you put God first,
you know I do believe that you
will get the results that you need.
Even of course you're going to be
challenged, you're going to go to many,
many meetings and people
are going to say no to you,
but for me each time I hear
no and like I'm one, you know,
and one notch closer to a yes because I
totally believe in the law of averages.
Everybody cannot see no.
At some point you're going to get to
that yes is that he has going to help me
break even that month and I can be
able to pay my salary is that month.
At some point you have to understand
that you can't go into business thinking
that you're gonna make a huge profit.
As soon as you set up that business,
that business has to grow.
You're going to have to look at the
fact that you may not be able to take
extensive holidays so you not able to do
all the things you could even do whilst
viewer fully employed.
What are the sacrifices that you're
ready to make to make that business work?
Because sometimes we're not
ready for the sacrifice.
You want to continue living the life that
you lead when you are being paid nine
to five and there was a big company
car and there was this and that was the
other.
You may have to just take a step back
to see what those things are that you're
going to have to just say, well, I
can't do that for now. You know? So, um,
yeah,
I don't think that to answer the question.
Absolutely very, very well. And you
talk, talking about making it work right?
With the Florence associates,
that was an area of your expertise
because you were head of Exxon Mobil.
Yes,
that's a part that is a bit more familiar
for a lot of setting up a business and
your area of expertise. But that does
not guarantee success. It doesn't.
So what were the things that you
put in place to make it work?
Well, the first thing I did
was to get a small office. Um,
make sure that I employed a few experts
that I could afford at the time. Um,
because one thing I find about going into
entrepreneurship is that sometimes the
people,
the best people that you want your
content really afford them because they're
themselves want to become entrepreneurs
and they want to do other things. So,
you know,
you have to sort of calm the markets to
find the best people that you can, um,
and offer them the necessary incentives
for them to come on board as part of
your team. So that was really
important for the being an HR person.
They knew that it was important
to have the right team in place.
So it's about having the right team.
It's about,
it was about having a work environment
and that I thought was attractive enough
for clients to be able to visit.
Um,
it was about setting up all those
processes and procedures they can show you
have a phone that's working,
they can show you have letterhead and
the can you have an email address.
I mean in those days there was
only high Perrier so I emailed,
nothing was Vic had high period.com.
Um,
it's not like today where you can
sort of, you know, doors. It's,
it's incredible how things have changed.
But at one point,
or you could do in their journal to get
an imminent as what you had to go to
high period. Um, so we had Vicky,
taper.com set up all the people work
and then you start the cold calling,
you then start to run in your business.
You then start going out
for business meetings.
You then start trying to persuade everyone
to come on board and to do business
with you.
And what I used to say to my team then
was that you can't go in there Dijuan
expecting that they're going
to give you that business.
They're going to have to find it.
There has to be a pure three of which
are going to have to go out there,
find out what their needs are and keep
going back and keep going back until at
some point you're going to pick up neither
some small small crumbs and then in a
near turn into,
you know,
prove yourself and then they're going
to trust you more and they're going to
trust you more. And I think that's
basically what we started doing.
We just made sure when we're just out
there every day covering every possible
opportunity that we found, you know,
with all the bands, with all the Telcos,
with all the FMCG is with absolutely.
Even in those days even, you know,
public sector government work. So we're
just basically just out there, you know,
just sort of reaching out to everyone.
Um,
and what I noticed was that it was
important for me to be the chief marketing
officer of the company.
You can impress someone to do that role,
but ultimately lot of it bolted down to
what you were also doing in trying to
make things happen at the same time.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Very interesting. And I see
your point as well as an entrepreneur,
you're pretty,
you know,
you own the vision and the
chief marketer especially. Yes.
And you've got to get
everyone else to buy in,
into that vision and own the vision and
take responsibility for the achievements
of division.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then
you suck up into which was,
and I know before that then
there was the protest hotel,
local parks. It was awkward park.
So whilst I was busy with the Clarus,
what I had found was that there
weren't really any purpose built,
treating a conference facilities in
Nigeria would use the Sheraton hotel.
Any character would just,
the equal hotel would even use
a place called city TCC augury,
which is outside of Lagos
on the way to Egypt. Um,
and in those days there were no fools.
They don't know falls.
I need today the world has changed.
People don't know how lucky they are.
A time setting up the business in the
Nigeria of today versus what it was like
back then. You know, so I would
have a teen in TCIS yogurt,
I'll be dialing the number two,
get some new to them.
Maybe after a hundred tries I would get
through to some landlines are started
with it's six zero, whatever
it was in those days, you know,
so we did a lot of training there. Um,
so for me the challenge then was, okay,
you're going to focus on
training and development,
but where are the purpose built
centers for this it cover turn.
There could be a wedding going on next
door and you have a training event going
on. People can't concentrate. Pretty much
the same happened at the Sheraton Hotel.
Jesus,
you're what's really far.
I started thinking about putting
together a center, you know,
started pretty much as just a center that
could, you know, you could sleep there,
you could also have the
training center there. Um,
and then one fine day I was at a cocktail,
which is why it's important
to go out and network.
And then I want you to Dick
Kramer, the cleaners, a lovely, um,
old Amanda's been in Nigeria probably
for about 50 years is actually a set of
essential and KPMG and it's been like a
mentor to me over the years. And I said,
Dick, you know, I've got
this project, you know,
we really want to start my own sort of
like TCC augury um, and said to me about,
no,
why don't you brand it?
Why not get a group like the
Protea hotel involved to brand?
So that now got me off on
another trail of, okay,
let's see if we can get them involved.
And eventually, initially they said no,
but sometimes people say, no, you
have to ask, why are they saying no?
So went back again and again and again.
Eventually they said yes,
we had done some plans initially we had
to change the plans to the most suitable
to a hotel.
The cost of investment of building the
Pulitzer Hotel went off like 10 fold from
it. Just being a little nice
little screening center to it.
Now having some sort of, you
know, three star standard. Um,
of course I was invested in it.
Um,
and I found that my investment in terms
of my shareholding was dwindling because
I couldn't afford to take on the
huge investment that it was. I mean,
also the five at the time,
the project cost in those days was $10
million and I just wasn't to be able to
do it alone. So I have to say to myself,
do you want to see this become a reality?
Even though you may only,
you may end up owning a smaller share
or do you just want to sit back and say,
well,
I'm just in a good and a little center,
which may not get all this
branding and this, you know, um,
or do you want others to come
in and be a part of it so that,
that you can be a much bigger dream?
And I said to myself,
I'm going to go the route of
letting me get other investors in.
So they've got Uba trustees involved.
Um,
we also got a mid will show
his involvement as the ink.
And that's basically how we got
that project off the ground.
So that was my second major project
after having left Exxon mobile.
Um, and then it was a few years
after that. But um, yeah, I dunno.
Sometimes I, yeah, the idea is just
calm. And I think that sometimes for me,
um, when I'm invited to speak on being
asked, you know, what inspires you,
where do the ideas come from?
I have to just see is God,
my son is a little bit basic and it
sounds simple in its sound. Yeah. Right.
But that is the truth because what
I find often happens to me is,
and I will say this to anyone,
never go to sleep without a notepad,
by your bed and a pen.
Because for me,
any idea that I've had is coming
in the middle of the notes,
that Aha moment to just yes. And, and,
and those ideas come and I find
that if I haven't noted it down,
by the time you wake up, you may have
forgotten it. So I find that it's,
the clarity for me is always at some
point in the middle of the night.
And I instantly just wake up and then I
just write and write and write and write.
And then I transfer that into some
sort of PowerPoint presentation.
And then I needed to go out
there and sell the idea.
So that's happened one night. The
Inspire African dream, just key.
Even the name is my Africa cane.
Um,
the name more with mold
didn't come for a while,
but what have you been thinking? What
was it like literally out of the blue?
Because it looks like you're very
good at identifying gaps in your mind.
Hmm.
So was that sort of in the space?
You know,
and we're thinking and then
you've got clarity. Yeah,
well it's sort of just like
a light, like a flash. The
thing is, you know, the even ends
a little bit in setting up get,
Lawrence was easy because it wasn't easy,
but pretty much it was the same
line of what I'd been used to.
And then sort of during the hotel
project I wasn't going to run the hotel.
So again, I could see that. Okay. And
it was also, there was some sort of,
you can see the alignment between and
Mclarens and our servicing. Yes. Um,
the Pulitzer Hotel at the time.
So this move in some moments
with Mo when that one came,
I was concerned, I was concerned
because you know how you're like,
why are you going to tell? What are
people going to think, you know? Um,
and you know, we live in a society
whereby sometimes, you know,
people get the wrong end of the stick,
you know,
and then we're telling a particular
person about the sound or the person could
see if the hair wants to become
a presenter to the presenter.
But for me it was more than that.
It was about the fact that we needed to
be able to have a conversation around
the things on the issues that are
important to us as a people within the
continent. And within Nigeria
more specifically. I mean, yes,
I have watched the Oprah Winfrey show. I
have watched the Ellen degeneres. I mean,
I can't do the Ellen thing. I mean,
she's so funny. I like how did she do it?
I don't know. You know, at the time
there was dozens of terror that's shoe.
So there were all these shows.
Well on the end, that platform.
So I went in to have a discussion with
them that um, about the fact that,
you know, when I gathered the courage
and I had done the presentation at,
this is what happens with a lot of
people about the idea of, you know,
went in to do a presentation to them
just to see what they would think.
And the initial response at the time was,
why do we need to show,
we already have a lot of talk shows and
it's incredible how the nude for local
content has changed in
the last 12 to 13 years.
Because then we didn't even have,
we didn't seem to have an
appetite for looking at content.
We didn't seem to crave it.
We did seem to want it.
We don't seem to carry for dentists.
Well, if it didn't even exist.
So I kept saying to them, I think there's
been to be a need for sure like this.
And my reasons are that yes,
I am traveling.
I can relate to some of the topics and
the things that have been said on those
shows. I mean, if I want me to go,
if needed that particular day or posts
talking about weight loss and they're
going to be talking about eating asparagus
or carrots or whatever they may be,
but how is that relevant to a Nigerian
entity that wants to lose weight,
where it should be to
find a struggles we're in?
So for me it was about bringing this
message home and seeing that how do we do
with issues in our environment it's in
that is beating his wife and you know,
she's a victim of domestic abuse.
How is that sure in America born to help
her overcome that battle in Nigeria.
Meanwhile, there are so many associations
that are dealing with domestic abuse,
who you can call out to in Nigeria who
were having no facetime about having that
conversation with people that they can
say, listen, if this is happening to you,
I'm here to help you.
I was a victim now I'm evictor.
There were no opportunities for that.
How come we're not celebrating our own
people that were achieving certain things
in the world of fashion and
music and so on and so forth.
Now we have all the blogs,
we have all of that.
We didn't have those things 12 years ago.
All we had the humbler city people,
if he wanted to know what
was happening to x, y, zed,
if it's totally comes
alive in the last decade,
it has exploded,
you know?
So it was really about telling them
that there was a need. Then God,
eventually Joe Honda, who was then the
mg of Avnet eventually said, okay Mo,
I'm going to buy this idea, but
you know what? I can afford it.
I don't have money to condition you,
but I will license your show.
So he now suggested that
you go to look for sponsors.
I've kind of been in the sponsor's
game prior to starting moments with my,
I didn't have a clue, but I thought, okay,
in England I don't, during the summer,
I don't know this sort of sales jobs and
I've been told you can't sell signs to
the tuition, so go out there
and sell. So I went around,
I went to the banks,
I went to the Tel calls to try and sell
moments with more looking at what would
the benefits be, an opening billboards
saying brought to you by Xyz company,
adverts in between the show product
placements, maybe if your color is red,
will have read in the background. So I
had to now start thinking about, okay,
what are all those things I'm
going to do to get them to commit?
Because you can't just keep saying to
somebody, be a sponsor. What is the value?
What is the value you're
giving to the sponsor?
And then it happens to us everyday
people going to sit in, I need a partner,
major partner,
how you want the exposure on the channel,
but what are we getting in return?
So we need to get value so that we
can give you some value as well.
So that's sort of opened up my eyes to
the world of sponsorships and how to
close those sort of sponsorship
deals. And um, you know,
had gone to one particular bank at
the time and they were like, Oh yes,
I wanted the Md.
Had said we're going to do it,
and then this particular MD and not later
hired a new head of corporate who now
said, we're not going to do it,
and I was totally like devastated,
but I thought to myself, am I going
to let that get me down? I said, no,
to pick myself up.
I caught a good friend of mine at the
time called Maca Darcy who runs a swirling
Cavita. I'm consulting, you know
mark? I said, Mark Seniors, your job,
you're not supposed to.
They did. What do I do now?
And at the time I was looking for a
huge amount of money to start this show.
He said, look, break it down.
Why don't you just see if we could
even do one season of this show.
If you do one season successfully,
then you can start grilling from there.
That advice basically is what happened.
It took me a while to
have a meeting with them.
Then the MDL stay back and session,
like in February I did my
usual presentation to him.
I've never met the man in my entire life.
And I walked in there thinking,
I wonder what he thinks.
And eventually he said,
we're not going to sponsor but we
want to invest in your company.
And then they have the SME scheme and
they bought into inspire Africa and that
basically gave us the seed capital.
We needed to go build our own studio
because we had to do the old space when
we're going to have this conversation.
It doesn't exist.
It's not like in the space where
you can just walk into a studio,
dry hire the studio and record.
We couldn't do that.
So we then have to sort of get our studio
space and with within a city mall and
an empty space,
we sort of did it up as best as we could.
And that's what we started doing this
and before the went on a training course.
Yes, yes, yes.
Recall hearing you say that you have
never done it before. It was, I'm
going into a new space. Yes, yes.
How did you develop your
own capacity and also, um,
position yourself in a
way that you and the show?
Well,
before we started,
thank God we had Skype and so they came
on board as an investor and also as a
sponsor.
And Luckily,
eventually I was able to persuade
Ntn to come on board as a sponsor.
So I have two strong brands that were
associated with the moments with move
brand.
And the very first interview I did,
my goodness was professor want to show
income and I chased and chased till he
said yes because I thought I need
to start the show with a band.
I need to have a really special guest.
And that's,
that sort of did the show the
credibility that it needed.
I went on a training course to
learn how to be a presenter.
At the time Oprah had launched
her 25 years, you know,
those sort of video DVD boxes.
I bought the entire thing I
would watch and watch, um,
running a training consultancy firm.
I've got one of my instructors turn,
you'll see or see me at
the time to train me.
So would train every weekend I'm at
the protein hotel. He would record me,
would play back,
would look at you no more.
You need to improve on
this and improve on that.
So I did all those
things if I got started.
So that kind of gave me a little bit
of confidence. I was still very um,
nervous.
But I just found that once I got
into the flow of the conversation,
I, once I was researched, it's important
to prepare for your interviews. Um,
so I think a lot of advice to young
girls out there that want to become
presenters, it's not really about how
you look or the shoes you have on. Yes,
that's nice too.
But it's really going to be about the
quality of the conversation and the
questions that you're asking and
the topics that you'll select it.
Because I found when I launched
notice I was, I kept saying,
we need to have topics that are exciting
and people are gonna want to watch.
So one of my episodes was this lady,
um,
that said that she was the parent to 11
to seven children that she claimed she
had in seven months. So we did
lots of research about, okay,
well for the blood test
we interviewed her.
She was a parent at the end of the
return that she wasn't the parent. Um,
I had another crazy episode
with a alarm robber.
This guy was an ExxonMobil and he
sat and told me and Tyler will,
how we got into it and
how we got out of it. Um,
another crazy episode was the snake,
the snake eating episode actually faces
physically can ground by sneaking it in
Nigeria.
And it's neat.
I'm thinking and the lady
came to the studio with the
sneaker looks like chicken,
I cetera and try this one today.
So it was really about finding
those topics that would engage,
that would be interesting rather than
just another, you know, domestic abuse.
We covered, of course, we celebrated
lots of people on the shows. Um,
I mean I probably did a thousand episodes
before I decided that I wanted to kind
of take a back seat before we sort of
started on this journey of ebony life
television still on moments.
So you have several moments in the
course of I think it's over 10 years now.
Yes, yes, yes. 2016 yes.
So in 2006 to 2016, 10 years. Yeah.
From the discussions whether
personal lessons that you've learned
that really had a profound impact.
The thing is when people that
you don't know open up to you,
they literally be, you find yourself in
a situation whereby you think you really,
I mean, that's sharing things within
that she may otherwise not have known.
And one of the episodes that I did for
me that was very early on in my career
that I found really touching was when
that plane crashed in for support and it
had all those children from the, um,
the school dinner, which own the flight.
And I had Mrs and McCree
who lost her only daughter
that [inaudible]
the studio and it was sitting
next to a woman that has,
she not only does she come on the show,
but she was able to share her pain and
you know how she dealt with the fund that
her only child has been
killed in a plane crash.
And you find that those intimate moments
are just moments where you're like,
you can never just get
them back and you know,
people are sharing things
with you that are really,
really private and you're the custodian
of that inflammation and how you treat
it and how you treat
them. I found to be, um,
I had to find my own way of dealing
with those kinds of issues and he would
leave a show at times and you're
like, oh my God. And you then,
and I used to do like four shows a
day because the world of production,
that's the only way can make financial
sense or can, we didn't want it to,
you use the cooler to use your,
they'd still be recording. So, um,
so at times you'd have to go from doing
a very happy episode to doing a very sad
episode to doing a different sort of
episode and how to your head is kind of,
yeah,
like in different places and I'm coming
from a world where I haven't done this
before. So having to deal
with all of that was kind of,
yeah. Challenge had its challenges. Yeah.
Yeah. And it sounds like
it was a lot of hard work.
It's wrong
what you see on an
entrepreneurial success story.
It's very easy to
celebrate it and to think,
told him why am etc. But
there's a lot of hardware,
genuine hardware that goes into
making anything successful.
Very much so. A lot, a lot of hard work.
You've got to be worried with searched
on whoever the guest is and if anyone
asked in Professor Alicia, and I
thought, you know what? He's like,
you can't fit on the set with, you might
not know what you're talking about.
So I was petrified of that particular one.
I must have read and read
and read more than you know,
then I would meet for the interview.
But you just have to be prepared for
every single interview that I did.
I had to do our research,
I have to have my questions
with me and sometimes you know,
the response you get has no
link to the next question.
So you have to be very quick on your feet
about how you're now going to sort of
go back to them and get the necessary
answers that you wanted. Um,
and at times we're going to
have technical problems on set.
Something isn't working.
The generator has Brooklyn.
You're like dealing in an environment
whereby your counterparts in another
country doesn't have to
think about these issues.
Nobody cares who cares about Palo,
who cares about some of those things here.
But here you are dealing
with those realities.
Those are my reality is everyday
that I have to deal with.
Find a space when I could
convert into a studio,
find stuff that would
understand the vision that
could get me the look and feel.
Because at the time,
as easy as it is,
I mean now that we do a
thousand hours of programming,
it talks show is the
easiest format in the world,
but no one has to been able to replicate
the moments with Newforma in 10 years
and not seen in other talk show that has
replicated the look and feel of talk.
And for us talking to the simplest
thing for us on Ebony Life TV today,
we've taken talk to it. It's completely
different level from things like moments.
Um,
now we have women's Z,
which is with a much younger crop of
young girls who are having a conversation.
One of the things that are important
to them. We have love lounge,
which is about love,
sex and relationships.
We've got men's corn and just talk about
things that men are fascinated about.
You know, that women also wants to
know about them. Um, we have the broad,
which is doing well or doing his
own crazy thing. It's all talk.
So we've taken the talk and
we've kind of given it a twist.
So it's, um, it is a lot of
work. It is a lot of work.
Even convincing sponsors to come on
board after you convince them, oh yeah,
pay me. You're going to be chasing
them around today. Payment. No,
you have salaries to pay.
You have cool young anybody else to be,
they're not going to wait
for clients to pay you.
You're talking to the bank and you know,
facilitating overdrafts,
say when they get, didn't all kinds of
things just to keep the business going.
Yeah.
So talking about everything life too.
That's one of your more
recent home groups. Yes.
And I remember the timeline,
oh, about Africa is about to
change forever. Forever. Yes.
You share the vision behind that.
The vision behind that was that,
I remember a few years before then I'd
interviewed Hillary Clinton and one of
the key questions that I said to her was,
how do we change the stereotypes about
how we are perceived across the world?
And she said to me,
we have to have people like you speaking
on behalf of Africa and putting a
different image out there about the
continent. Because even with Google,
if you Google Africa, what are
the first than in does it come up?
Is going to be poverty, it's going to
be this, it's going to be destruction.
It's going to be all of these images that
the world view have of our continent.
How do we change that world view?
It's by creating the reality.
That's the other reality
that the world needs to see.
And that other reality is showing that
the people like him and I in Nigeria
showing up as this audience here
showing that we have, we are capable.
And that was how we
came up with a tagline.
Every think you think you know about
Africa is going to change because we put a
positive spin on everything.
We didn't create these people.
These people already existed,
just didn't have a platform through
which you could engage with them.
So he gave that platform for
engagement from let's make comedy.
That's nick reality. Let's make talk.
Let's make speech at programming.
That's to lifestyle.
Let's,
let's do everything that we can to show
the world that this, we have a tiger.
You know, we have the stamp
that we put on everything,
say ebony life TV made
in Nigeria for the world.
So good things can come out of our
constant and out of our country and can be
exported. And, and, and that really
was what it was all about. I mean,
we go out to international
exhibitions, um, and people ask us,
I don't know if it's a compliment
or an insult, they said,
what's this really needy Nigeria? Yes,
it was made in Nigeria. How about that?
I guess we can make things like that
because they're so used to just all kinds
and we have to be careful
about what we put out there.
And, uh, actually interestingly,
that's one of our priorities
as Google in Nigeria.
Just encouraging having local contents.
Yes,
yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes.
Let me look at this conversation
we're having today. I mean, it is,
you're having it, so thank you. Yeah.
Challenges that you
encountered in trying to set,
because that's a really big fits right
in setting up your own TV channel.
Um, everything you've
mentioned, parts of that.
I know that there were very challenging,
but this I think was the,
in order of magnitude.
Yeah.
What are the challenges that you
went through in setting and money?
Setting up and running everything
like TV and what support systems and
opportunities are.
Okay.
I wake up one day and I decided that I
wanted to launch a TV channel and um,
I had no idea how I was getting to do it,
but I just knew that deep down in my
spirit to deep down in my soul, God said,
moe, go and do this. It's scary.
Very scary. Very. And I think
sometimes hysteria the dream,
the more you need to pursue it because
I think there's a message in there
somewhere. Cause if it's not
scary, then was the challenge.
And I'm funny, I'm like,
okay, oh you have to do is try. If
it doesn't work, it doesn't work.
So the idea came and one of the
festival I called was my mom.
My mom is always, she's
my prayer partner. Um,
and she said she's my number one fan.
So I said, Mommy, I'm doing this thing.
My worry. I drank, I drank low,
has she always says that
she's paying about it.
So the next lesson I took was a
friend of mine in South Africa,
Sandra [inaudible], Sandra's one of our
producers. Then on moments, cause let me,
didn't want us just to have a Pan African
spin to a lot of our shoes and she
would go around Africa sort of shooting
similar stories for the show at the time.
So I said to Sandra, started to reach
and, and sound was like, oh, I know.
Sounds really cool and um, what
do we do now? Um, so I thought,
how did you start to challenge,
you know, I couldn't get a license.
There was opportunity to get a license for
free to edit, all been taken, all gone.
Um,
but I also felt that it was important to
create a platform that could travel and
one could use technology to drive and
we'd be Pan African at the same time.
So I had a show on the STV as a,
let me have a conversation with DSTV.
So Joe Honda than had approved
the initial aneurysm. I said, Joe,
I want to start a TV channel. And
it's like, well no, have, you know,
they don't just do channels like that,
you know,
I'm not sure we need another channel
but you can try it. So I said,
who do I contact? And as it needs to
contact political Alexa Albert's as I can.
I have an email address. So he gave me
her email and this is how it starts.
I didn't know her from Adam sent her
an email and eventually she responded.
She sent me a form that's longer than
anything else. Hundreds, not hundreds,
but several pages of what is the
name of the channel? What is the con?
I mean questions that I did not even
know because it made me think about, wow,
you want to start a channel?
What did you know you're going to have
to know this much before you can actually
start the channel of the schedule, the
types of programs, you know, the budget.
I mean,
there was so many questions.
Eventually I did the best I could to
answer the questions and I sent the form
back to her.
And then I kept chasing her and chasing
her and she wasn't answering me because
I didn't, they get requests
at least 10 to 23 d from,
you don't want to set up to the
channels from Nigeria. So, um,
eventually I said,
I'm going to be in South Africa because
I was shooting an episode of [inaudible]
and could I please come in and see you?
So that was my hope of getting in the
door. So I went in and had a meeting.
So before having the meeting,
I then hired someone that was already in
the world of media to do me a beautiful
presentation around this as a sort
of content would have on the channel.
Went in and did the presentation and
left the meeting. They said, well,
this doesn't, this isn't quite, it's,
I was devastated because I actually paid
someone quite a large sum of money to
do that presentation. Um, it
wasn't working so they were like,
if you want this channel, you
have to go back and do x, y,
zed,
and we had workshop after workshop after
workshop deciding on who was going to
be our key Dev. Who Do you really
want to speak to across the continent?
What is the conversation? What other
John [inaudible], what are the hours?
How are you going to produce these hours?
Who is going to produce these hours?
Who is going to do your post production?
How are you going to clear
things through legal?
I mean there is a battle and in half of
things you need to play to create one
hour of content.
So eventually after several
months of now having gone back,
having left them and gone back to do
another presentation with all of this,
if I had to engage a consultant,
Axonify,
then one in Nigeria to do it
because the skill sets don't exist.
I found someone in South Africa again
had to invest a huge amount of money that
could have gone into maybe
an ice bag on a holiday.
Let's just get this presentation down,
letting us do the strategy session.
After which we then did the presentation
without once back into mortgage choice
to present. Then they bought the
idea, but now they gave us conditions.
This is a beautiful presentation,
but you need to raise x, y,
zed amounts of money.
You need to have his studio before
you can do all of this. So you know,
which is why I said sometimes you
need to pray harder, work hard.
At the same time,
a good friend of mine,
I had to raise the money and the story
about how that reads is what I'd like to
share. At the same time, all this
is happening. A good friend of mine,
[inaudible] says to me, you need to go to
cross river and interview the governor.
And I was like,
I'm kind of his money for my channel.
I'm trying to do all these things.
I don't really know.
But eventually she persuaded me and I
also had wanted to do that into for the
longest time.
I got on a plane on new years day,
about five years ago,
went to caliber to go and
do this interview with His
Excellency than at the time
governor really murky and
his wife are the at the time.
But at the same time I had a sponsor for
my show moments with Mo and the support.
So had threatened to pull out unless I
started having a presence on social media
cause I wasn't switching. I was,
I didn't know anything about,
I was just doing my thing.
I've got a PR person
registered me on Twitter, do
my Facebook and do all of that.
So when I got to caliber that evening,
I sent a message saying happy new year,
lots of law, firm caliber. And someone
said to me, what's happening in turnover?
I've never been entered in
that point in my entire life.
So I was with a friend in the car
who said, let me take you there.
Let's drive around. We went
there, beautiful place,
beautiful but empty as
nothing was into Napa.
So the next day when I was going
to interview the governor, um,
then in Zion ob who was a
special assistant said come
in and have a conversation
with his. That's the lesser,
before you start your
interview. I did never, nothing,
I didn't know what to say to him.
The first thing I said was you accidents.
We wanted to not pay as well.
He's Very Mc. What's going on.
That is how that conversation started.
That is how they got the supports
would be needed for the channel.
Now I didn't know,
I mean on one hand you are looking
to set up a channel and another hand,
a friend is saying come
and interview the governor.
You have a sponsor saying
you need to start to meeting.
You put all of that together,
you send a tweet message
out and Bob's your uncle.
Somehow a couple of years later,
about 18 months later,
Cross River state came
on board as our partner.
We promised to use that to another studio,
um,
as our destination point for media.
And that was the catalyst for getting
ebony life TV started and they also
supported us.
Have the fundraising for Ebony Life TV.
So at times without putting
all those elements together.
So when people say to you, what is
your recipe? I can't say to you,
don't tweet or don't go to
[inaudible] with the governor.
You're going to have to just work hard
enough from the universe to conspire to
say, okay, I am going
to give you your break.
I believe that there are dream
makers for all of us out there.
We won't have to meet our dream
makers. And on the other hand, yeah,
you are dream killers. Those are just
the kind of way to kill the dream.
So you have to balance,
you know,
the dream killers and the teenagers makers
and see how you get out of that cycle.
Yeah.
That's lesson I hear as well from just
this thing to use is also having your
reader on.
Sometimes you think it's going nowhere
and sometimes for the hell of it,
just go along with whatever it is
because you never know where it's going.
Lead to never ever know. It could be
one night you're out having a drink.
You could be in a supermarket,
you could be absolutely anywhere
when the opportunity comes to you.
Yeah. Yeah. Another thing
I think is very good at,
and I think that's really critical,
negative inertia is
finding the right talents.
Whether you saw Stalins and whatever
seems to be helpful because when I think
about ebony life TV and everything
you do actually, you have a great day.
We have a fantastic team. How
do you find them? Um, again,
I think the universe will conspire
to sort of be the right people,
but I think maybe being a hatred person
I think also has helped a great deal in
understanding what the processes are
that you need to go through to find the
right talent. You know, I can't
work with anyone on my team,
but he's not ready to be playing
email at three o'clock in the morning.
I know it sounds crazy, but you
know, you must be able to work hard.
You've got to be able to identify
where they're coming from,
the things they've done.
I mean,
there's someone here with me
to do is with me today. Um,
and Eunice was based in America and I
have to plead with her to come back to
Nigeria to work with us because even
before she joined us as a member of our
team, as a head of strategy,
we had already started
working together on little,
little things, not officially, like
it was going to go to the states.
She would even proactively volunteer
should proactively help me do things
without me even asking.
And I'm thinking,
this is the sort of person you want on
your team to be there for you in your own
corner. Um, and so eventually I
pleaded and said, please come back.
And she packed up her bags and she's
come back to Nigeria. Um, you know,
so for me it's really about just putting
your feelers out there and you need to
have that fifth sense.
You need to be able to say to yourself,
is this person going to be
a part of your team? And He,
you can pretty much sauce are people
that work hard and people that are just
[inaudible]. I'm sorry to
say that, you know, I mean,
there are lot of people that just,
they're all talk and they're just not
going to do the work and I can't deal with
that, you know? So it
needed me. I would attend.
You're going to make recruitment
errors and when you do,
you said thank you very much, but it's
not going to work out. Bye Bye. You know,
and then you move on to the next person.
And that's pretty much
how I built the team. Um,
but I think more than anything it's
really just about finding people that can
come plug in.
And we have a lot of young people with
us and they want a car ahead of social
media. Let's say she joined us, I don't
know, three, four years ago. And you know,
it's incredible how she has
grown into her job, you know?
And it's really just about finding the
right team of people and then sharing the
dream and then just being conscientious
about the things that they need to do.
And you're not having to see it a
million times before they do it and
micromanage them. You know,
for them to practice. What
about this, what about that?
You know,
and we're all learning together and I
like to have lots of people around me that
even know more than I do about certain
things because you don't know it all.
I don't know if my daughter is
working with ebony life now.
She's got some crazy ideas.
She's like, mom, we need to
do this. And I'm like, okay,
we're targeting your age. Okay,
I will listen to. So it doesn't,
for me it's about making sure we
have an inclusive team that you know,
they can tell us about things that they
think are going to work for the channel
of whatever business it is. And we
just fly with, with those ideas.
And because we're small for us, we're
able to just get things done very quickly.
We don't have to get to 10 levels
of approval before we do them in.
Be like you guys, I mean Google
it, there's going to be such a,
such a massive organization, um, but
with also can pretty much say, okay,
we're going to run with this so we can
execute things really quickly as a small
organization.
Awesome.
Questions from the audience,
but I'll ask one more question.
What keeps you in a joy?
Okay.
I think the, for me, the
highlights of my existence,
my children, you know, um,
I think that for me they are the
most important thing in my life.
If I had to give everything
I have for my kids,
I will do so tomorrows and really,
and I say that 100%. I would,
um, my mom is my, you know,
she's my everything, my sisters.
Um, I put God before
everything. I absolutely do.
I just think it's so important for
me to have that sense of direction.
And you know,
what I find interesting is that people
don't often know your relationship with
God and the neck assumptions about
how you've achieved certain things.
They don't even know how
you've achieved them.
And what I find interesting is that,
that is my secret. I shadowed a lot,
but I think sometimes they're not
listening to the fact that if you put him
first, if you listen to
him TV, it doesn't matter.
I've got this thing six inches
on. I've got my lashes, the web,
you in my moments when I'm
on my knees praying to him,
it is between him and I
having that conversation and
he's saying, more do this.
This is the most important thing for
you to do. So he guides my every,
every move that I do and he just gives me
the confidence to go out there and say,
there's nothing that is really too much
that we can't achieve because with him,
you know that all things absolutely
possible and that that's,
that's what I continue to believe him.
Yeah.
So I'm going to pause my and see if there
are any questions for our very lovely,
yeah.
I think for me,
the schools that I started with most
Appleby my people skills because I'm so
impatient to get things done at times
that I'm sure I'm driving everybody around
me crazy because I kind of like wanted
to happen now because at times I'm like,
I might probe manage,
I would do it to myself if you can't give
it to me now I'm that kind of person.
Um,
what I think that as we grow,
I think skills are something
that with age you get better,
you'll get better at them because I know
I'm a much better person now than I was
10 years ago, 20 years ago.
So I think it's gradual. Um,
and I think it's also important to keep
learning about the skills that you have
that you need and to practice.
I find I practiced the skills that I need.
You know,
even public speaking at times I practice
because I'm not the best public speaker
I want to be.
And I'm constantly challenged by the fact
that I'm not going to say no to going
out and speaking in public, but I'm going
to learn to be a better public speaker.
So it's really about teaching
yourself those skills that you need.
And I think skills come with habit.
Once you practice it enough times
then becomes a reality for you.
So whatever skills that you think you
lacking, just work out them. If it's a,
you're not smiling,
you know what keeps smiling,
it's mild enough times you're going to
find yourself just smiling without even
thinking about it because the
mind is a very funny thing.
It just kind of just takes over and
does those things without even thinking
about it.
From my own personal experience,
it's, it's pretty, from my experience,
it's pretty much been about the fact that
you need to share the dream. You know,
if you have a big dream,
you can't do the dream by yourself.
You're going to have to look for other
people that you can invite him to make
the dream a reality.
Um,
when I was setting a lot of the chlorine's
I didn't need support because it was,
I started very small, but when I
moved on to do the [inaudible] hotel,
Oakwood Park, it was a $10
million. I don't have $10 million.
I had to now go out there and do
a proper placement, informal, um,
you know, and get people to buy
into the project and it takes time.
You're not going to say to someone come
and invested in and I've got to just
sign the check tomorrow. No. Some will say
yes, some will say no. So there was it,
there's a,
there was a process of engagement.
It's pretty much the same thing happened
with moments with Mo had to go out
there, as I said earlier and engage
and get people to buy into the dream.
Ebony Life TV was the same thing.
I didn't have the required
capital to set up a TV channel,
so I had to find a partner. And those
dreams can sometimes take time, you know,
to, to become a reality because
cash is king and you need the cash.
But you just have to just keep watch
dear focus that you want to achieve this.
When those things will come
into the plea in that, you know,
and I said with moments of
when I started with one season,
but initially my whole idea was I was
looking for money to get me comfortable
for a year. I want, I couldn't
find one or three year,
I decided to take Max advice
and just do one season.
So if you can find ways to start small,
then you start small.
And then once people can see success back.
Now everybody in agile wants to do a
film after the success of the parts.
And they're like, can we come up our
time with you? Do you want money?
People are offering us money to partner,
you know, so success has its own,
you know, successes. And then others
will come and say, can you come and be,
you know,
the parts of your own success.
So once you can achieve some
level of success, then you
just have to just invite,
but never be afraid of inviting people
in to share in your dream. I mean,
you've got to be careful,
do your due diligence and all of that,
but all things being equal,
nobody.
I don't think there's anyone that owes
anything a hundred percent anymore.
It doesn't happen
if that,
that is a tough one because you know,
there are some women that decide that
when it's time to raise the kids, I'm out.
I'm just going to focus
on raising my children.
And then there are some people like
me who are a little bit more selfish,
who believe that they can have everything.
So you need to be single minded about
the five that I love my children,
but at the same time I have this dream,
so how am I going to be able
to juggle all of those things?
You need to have a great
support system around you.
You need to spend quality time with
your children because I find a lot of
housewives that called themselves
housewives. They're not even at home.
Half the time they're probably out having
lunch or doing the nails or some way.
So they have deceived themselves.
That's the of it.
So in that regard you
that you are working,
you therefore make it. It became part of
my day to sit, I'm going to spend x, Y,
z amount of time with my
children. I'm gonna, you know,
we're going to go out on this day,
we're going to take this holiday,
we're going to do those things.
And when it's really tasteful
need to take myself out of work,
a hundred percent equity. My son was going
to go to his a levels and I daughter,
I had to physically take the time out
and say, I'm not working for a month.
I'm going to go.
We're going to have to search for,
we even do a levels in England and that
was it. And you close down, shop on,
you come back to do those things.
So it's really about prioritizing.
And I think what happens with working
mothers is that I think your kids become
strong.
I hope so.
Mine have might have
that they become strong.
Knowing that my mom is working.
You're also a role model to your daughter
that she's going to know that her mom
has worked your son. My mom has worked
hard so that when he marries his wife,
he's not going to say sits at home
because it's seen, it's one of us working.
So I think we're also preparing our
kids for the fact that it's okay to have
your dreams are valid to burrows.
Please don't be limited the suits for
plagiarism here, your dreams are valid.
You can take that on to know that you
can go out there and achieve your dreams
the same way that your husband
is achieving his dreams. Right?
So why can't you achieve
yours? So it's, it's,
I think it's just about finding the fact
that you need to find the happy medium,
that happy balance and you know,
have a good support system and to let
the kids know you really love them when
you're there.
That's what has worked for me.
But I can't say that sin recipe will
work for everyone because everyone is
different. You know,
we're not all the same.
So my DNA would be different
to the next person's DNA,
but that is pretty much what I have done.
Yeah,
that's interesting as well.
You touched on something.
Do you believe you believe
that it's possible?
Um, not all the time. I
think something will good.
You can't have it all, all the
time. You cannot, it's not possible.
So you have to decide on
what is important to you.
It's like the woman that decides to
stay at home with her kids that wanted a
career but couldn't have it.
She's had to give certain things off.
So I don't think anyone can have it all.
I think we just have to try and do the
best that we can and you know, live with,
you know,
just find the as good as we can really.
And to be honest with ourselves about
the capabilities and the capacities that
we have because we can't do everything.
The only certain things that we can,
we can do. Um, I think we need to
just look at ourselves and say,
this is who I am. Yes. When
I am in this mode of work,
I can be obsessive.
My Friends gonna think I'm selfish
because I didn't want to see anybody,
but it stops what gets me to
get the results that I need.
Then I'm going to do those things and
when I'm done then I will find a way to
just go back and get back into the
swing of things. And Yeah. Yeah.
I think we have a lot of talent in Nigeria
and if I look at the success of Ebony
Life Television,
it has been based on the fact that we,
I mean one of my biggest concerns at
the time when we actually started the
channel was where am I
going to find the talent?
Cause I looked at the TV landscape and
I was pretty much appalled by the titans
that I saw.
So I don't understand the hiring decisions
or how people decided to put certain
and look at TV. I'm like, why is this
person on TV? What skills do they have?
Why do they look this way?
So for me it was really important to
understand the look and feel that we're
after and then find the right people
that we could put into that looking for
living if they didn't have
the necessary experience.
I mean what means here today or Mimi when
we meet, um, she's, she does a lot of,
one was one of our presenters on the
channel and I remember that. How she,
I mean she's also, I mean she's tenacious.
I mean I remember how she hounded me.
Don at the time I said I wanted to become
a presenter on your channel and I was
like, we don't have any spaces. And
then she'll keep sending you emails.
And then I said, okay,
send me your showreel.
And then one day we needed to present a
full show and that's how she became one
of our best presenters. I mean she is
so off the mark with just anything. So,
but prior to that, did you have any
experience really? She had known,
but I don't think anybody knows who
she is today, two or three years later.
So the same applies to our channel. Even
a Buka that is doing the big brother in,
in, in South Africa is has been on the
spot and has been with us for many,
many years.
We have in lots of talents in Nigeria,
but I think the reason why big brother's
been shot there is for business
reasons. We are also shooting
in South Africa right now.
It's just for business reasons.
Also the world is a global village.
We can't keep limiting ourselves to,
oh,
I'm fighting this cause that
everything must be done in Nigeria. No,
I want to do programs in America.
I want to do programs in the UK.
Then I can sell to make UK broadcaster.
Why should my limit be
just in Nigerian market?
Especially with the night
I'd doing what is doing now
my guys and I actually off to England
to go and shoot some pilots and some of
our very good shows with a British cast
and we're going to go to America to do
the same as an American cast
because we need to widen the net.
Shonda Rhimes is a black woman just like
I am. She's written with an attorney.
I don't think everybody in
prison afternoons black, right?
So she's just a very talented person
that is doing great work in the big world
world of media. We have to learn
to take that on as well, and to be,
to understand that we can go anywhere
in the world and make a content and the
programming. That's, that's
what I think we need to do.
We need to just open the blinkers
and just see the world widely.
What it truly is,
and that's what I want to do now
that the Niara has crashed and
that you should do the same.